The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
DUANE BONING: OK.
As you'll see with
today's lecture,
I made a small change
in the lecture sequence.
I basically combined the last
part of Tuesday's lecture
with what I was going to talk
about next week because they
really go together better
anyway, which is multivariate
SPC together with a couple of
the advanced control charting.
And so next week we'll do
the yield modeling lecture
rather than try to
squish that in today.
So what I want to
do today is first
have a very brief warm up.
Just get us back into
the swing of things
with conventional control charts
and then talk a little bit
about these alternative
control charts
with a little bit of increased
sensitivity for rapid detection
of shifts, as well as drifts.
But primarily
targeted at shifts.
And these are the moving
average-- exponentially
weighted moving average and
the cumulative sum chart.
And then we'll move into
multivariate SPC, which
is a little bit of a tutorial
on multivariate statistics
in general.
So that's the plan.
So to get us warmed up we'll
do a rapid design of a control
chart.
How to do this
relatively quickly.
I will tell you that
we have a model based
on lots of historical
data of this process
that when it is in
control it's operating
as a normally distributed
process with a mean of 1
and a variance of 1.
We're going to be taking
samples every nine parts.
And then the next 9 and so on.
So what should the--
here's the easy one.
Wake you up in the morning.
What should the center line be?
AUDIENCE: 5.
DUANE BONING: 5.
OK.
Everybody-- how about
the plus minus 3 sigma?
We're quite happy
with the 1 in 370 ARL
with normal typical plus
minus 3 sigma control limits.
Where should the plus minus
3 sigma control limits be?
I hear a 6 and 4.
Why?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
DUANE BONING: I'm sorry?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DUANE BONING: OK.
Which is?
AUDIENCE: Mu plus
sigma [INAUDIBLE]..
DUANE BONING: Mu plus
sigma plus minus 3 sigma.
3 sigma over square
root of sample size.
And so the 3 sigma and the
3, which comes from the root
[? end ?] make it a
nice plus minus 1.
And there are some data.
OK.
So I plotted 99.
We ran the process 99 runs.
We have 11 samples.
Here's the question.
Is the process in control?
We have a yes.
We have another yes.
I contend you don't know.
It's a little bit tricky here.
AUDIENCE: Not the 1 [INAUDIBLE].
DUANE BONING: Yeah, I guess.
That's actually not
what I have in mind.
You could go in and start down
the path of looking and saying,
OK, what's the probability
of having, for example three
rising points in a row?
And all the other [INAUDIBLE].
But I'll say none
of that's happening.
So I will say that the mean--
there's nothing too strange
happening with the mean
that you can tell
with this chart.
Is the process in control?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
variance [INAUDIBLE]----
DUANE BONING: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
variance is getting huge
compared to earlier points.
DUANE BONING: Oh.
So you're saying the
variance is getting larger.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
variance-- yeah.
DUANE BONING: Maybe.
It's hard to tell with this.
This Is a mean chart.
All it's telling you is
the tracking of the mean.
We said that the process
model is that we have
this mean and this variance.
And so I guess the
main point here
is you don't really know if
you're just tracking the mean.
What's happening also with the
variance within your sample?
And in fact, on
the next page this
is the raw data-- all 99 points
where we grouped 9 by 9 by 9
to get the sample.
And if you saw this, you might
be a little less comfortable.
Now you could always go
back and look at raw data.
And raw data is always
really good to do.
But what you would
also want to do
is a typical S chart or a range
chart or something like that.
And in this case,
if you design the S
chart with those
apriori pieces of data--
sample size is 9 and the
process variance is 1--
with the C4 correction factor
and so on-- all of that just
out of the formula--
you get these control limits.
And sure enough,
at about sample 10
we're above the control limit.
Sample 11 is even more
above the control limit.
And that's indicative
of essentially
the increased variance
of those two groups.
And I will tell you, I
generated this data with JMP.
And sure enough, right
at the whatever it was--
the 77th point--
I re-sampled from a normal
distribution with something
like a variance of 1.9 or
2 or something like that.
So the main point here was you
need to monitor both aspects--
both the mean and the variance
to know whether your process
model is still operative.
We're saying that for
a normal distribution
the mean and variance are
really telling you everything.
Now, the other sub
point in here is
that if you were actually
looking at this run data,
there is a lot of noise.
There is inherent process noise.
And part of the
goal here is you're
trying to detect a mean
in the face of that noise.
And so one way of thinking about
sampling and calculating x bar
is that, indeed,
you are filtering.
OK.
So you want to
filter to suppress
the additional variance
effect when you're
looking for the mean phrase.
But again, you've got to also
monitor for the variance.
But this noise makes
it a little bit tricky
in terms of being able
to detect the means.
So you want to filter.
And one of the ideas of these
alternative control charts
is explicitly think about
the filtering action
that you're doing--
a little bit almost from
a more signal processing
point of view, but
not necessarily
have to wait for an
additional nine runs
before you call that a
sample, aggregate it,
and then plot it, and then
wait for another nine runs.
One alternative approach here
is to take a running average.
So I take a window, say, of
9 points and measurements,
calculate my statistics,
and then for each new run
move my window over and
recalculate my statistics
so that I'm in
some sense updating
what my best guess of the
current state of the process
is after every run.
And the advantages of
this are that you can get
more averages per unit of data.
OK.
You can go ahead and use the
run data alone if you wanted to.
You could actually
plot for example,
the individual measurements and
even do a hybrid sort of thing
where you did a
running average just
for the standard deviation.
But the real advantage of these
is they essentially improve
your ability to detect.
They improve the
filtering action
potentially because you can
play with that window size
to filter more but also be able
to react potentially faster.
So I'm going to
describe a couple
of these alternative charts.
And I'm going to focus
really on the running
average detection of the mean.
But the same idea also applies
to filtering of the variance
across multiple runs.
So there's also running S
charts or moving range charts
and those sorts of things.
So don't forget the lesson
we just learned a minute ago.
You got to monitor
both mean and variance.
But for the next 10,
15 slides I'm only
going to talk about running
averages on the average.
So one idea of the
running average
is a simple running
average or moving average
where we simply take
some n values of the past
and calculate say
a simple average.
And similarly, we can do
that for the variance.
So in that case, this
simplest picture,
this simple moving
average is just
an equally weighted window.
You pick your window size.
Maybe it's a window
size of 9 and you
calculate a new moving
average statistic, which
I've labeled m sub i here.
And so that's pretty
trivial formula.
Now how do you set
the control limits
on a moving average chart?
Well, you want plus
minus 3 sigma control
limits based on the
variance that you
expect in your statistic.
Right?
So previously we'd
have sample size of 9.
And we'd say, well,
what's the variance?
It's 1 over-- it's
sigma over root n
is the standard
deviation associated
with our normal sample size.
And that same formula
ends up working here
because we've got
equal weighting.
Right?
So if we simply apply, again,
assuming each of the points
are truly in process control
and I do not have correlation
in time between them--
it's very easy to see
what the variance is.
Now you'll notice
something a little strange
right here at the beginning.
This is kind of an artifact
of the startup of the chart.
Let's say I have just started
the use of the control chart
and I've only got
five samples so far,
but I've got a moving
average window of 9.
Well, I don't have
nine data points yet.
I have to form my moving average
really with a window size
only of 5 so far.
And because I'm taking
the variance divided
by 5 instead of divided
by 9, the variance
of my average of a five
point sample is larger.
And you can see
essentially each sample
until I get to my
full window size of 9,
has slightly larger
control chart limits.
OK.
So that's what's going on there.
And you can also
sort of see here now
the filtering action at work.
Notice that each
of these samples
don't vary dramatically
from the previous one.
They are no longer uncorrelated
from one sample to the next.
In fact, with this
equal weighting,
every new time point
shares 88% of the data
with the previous data point.
So there's a huge amount of
correlation from one point
in time in the next.
So you should not
try to use things
like the WECO rules
associated with three data
points in a row or four or five
data points in a row rising.
Those things are
right out because this
is a running control chart or
moving average control chart.
And you've now got correlation.
It's benefit though is that
it is doing that filtering.
And you can take
whatever current point
that you get as a
sort of your best
guess of what the current
state of the overall mean is.
And so you would
trigger on alarms
above or below the
control limits.
So simple moving average--
this is relatively simple.
Any questions on this
before we do a unequally
weighted moving average?
Pretty clear.
AUDIENCE: I have a
question, Professor.
DUANE BONING: Yes.
Good.
These questions have been
wonderful by the way.
The last couple of classes, I
think the questions have really
been right on target.
It's been a lot of fun.
So we have high expectations
for your question.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: OK.
So that's a lot of
pressure, but my question
is that for the
window size on 9,
so do the two windows
next to each other-- they
overlap by 8 data points?
DUANE BONING: Right.
AUDIENCE: OK.
That's it.
DUANE BONING: That's
exactly right.
AUDIENCE: OK, thank you.
DUANE BONING: Now, one problem
with that overlap of eight data
points is, by the time you
get to 8 points in the past,
it may be--
that's a long time ago,
depending on how rapidly you're
sampling or whatever.
And compared to the data
point that you just took,
you might think that
the data point you just
took represents the current
state of the process
a lot better than the
0.789 time points ago.
And so there is a more
general approach here,
where you can pick some
weighting for how much you
want to fold in data from
different points in time.
And a classic way
to do the weighting
is to use an exponentially
weighted moving
average, where you might
define the weighting function--
these a sub i's here--
I guess I've switched
notation to w here--
when I'm at the current sample
point or the current time point
t, I might weight points
backwards in time by index i,
i going from 1 to 9
to 1,000-- whatever--
by a function looking
something like this,
with some r factor, where
r is weighting factor.
So what happens here,
as I might think
of r as being how much I
believe my current data point--
might be I believe my
current data point by 90%,
and then the next data point,
1 minus r, is only 10%.
So I'm only mixing
in 10% of that.
And then the next data
point beyond that--
it's maybe 0.1 times 0.1.
It's only 0.01,
so I'm only mixing
in 1% of the
previous data point.
So very rapidly, I have this
drop-off as a function of data
points in the past--
this is my i index--
so that I much more heavily
weight recent history,
and then exponentially
decay into the past.
But I still have this
degree of freedom.
I can pick r.
I can pick the relative
weighting of more recent data
compared to old data.
Now, one way of
looking at this is,
actually, I have access
to all past data,
and I would apply
this out to 10 data
points, or 50, or 100 with the
appropriate weighting function.
And I guess, with computer
systems these days,
it would be no problem
to actually apply it
in that fashion.
There's a beautiful thing about
the exponentially weighted
moving average,
which is I actually
don't have to keep track
of all of the raw data.
There's another way
of thinking about what
the EWMA, this exponentially
weighted moving average
is doing.
And that's that I have
my previous best estimate
of the state of my variable--
of the mean--
and now I have one
new data point,
and I use that
one new data point
to update my best estimate.
My best estimate had embedded
in it all of the past history,
so now, with the
additional new weight,
I can just do a simple update
of my best state estimate.
And there is essentially
a recursive formula
that makes this explicit, and
it's exactly the same, thing
if you now apply it
iteratively out to all history,
as actually performing that
computation of applying
the weights on all past data.
So that is to say,
let's say, a sub i
is my best estimate of whatever
my statistic is-- my mean.
Again, I might weight
my current data point,
my most recent data
point, say, 90%,
which would be
really rapid update.
I really believe my
most recent data.
And then my 1 minus r
applies to my previous--
oops-- to my previous estimate.
So I'm believing only
10% my previous estimate,
and 90% my new estimate.
So it makes it a
little bit easier
in terms of the
computation, but I
think it's also
conceptually nice in terms
of what the action here is.
Now, one can go through and do
a little bit of the mathematics.
It's actually a little easier
to do it on the full summation
version, but you just do
basic expectation math
on the variance of an EWMA--
again, drawing from a
normal distribution that
is in control.
And one can estimate
the standard deviation
of this a statistic.
And it's kind of a
little bit messy.
It's got the underlying process
variation in it, the fact
that you are still--
you can still be doing sampling.
For each x sub i, that might
be a sample of n data points.
Very often, you might simply
be doing it one data point,
so n, very often, is just 1--
and then this formula with r
in it, including this 1 minus 1
minus r to the 2t, where t
is how far along you are.
So it's kind of nasty,
but one thing that's nice
is, once you've start
started up your control chart
and you're away from
that little artifact
that we saw with
the moving average,
where the variance
limits change--
once you get far enough
away from that start up,
your t is large, and that this
whole term just drops out--
drops out more fast when--
more rapidly for
large values of r,
because I'm really weighting
more towards recent history.
But even for small
or modest values
of r, after you get
out 10, 20 data points,
it typically drops away.
So now you've got an
estimate for large T
for the variance, sigma
a of your statistic,
and you can simply
plot plus/minus
3 sigma, or whatever
control limit you want,
depending on your
false alarm rate alpha.
So this is pretty cool.
One quick observation
here is, again, we still
have a lot of degrees
of flexibility
around the choice of r.
And if we look at this formula
here, and the effect of r--
I sort of plotted this
out in this next chart.
This effect of r on the sigma
multiplier-- oops-- sorry--
is this factor right here.
So in other words, as r changes,
how do my control limits move?
What is this multiplier
of my sigma over root
n from my normal sampling?
And you can look at it here.
And as r gets larger,
well, that gets larger--
as r approaches 1.
Typically, you don't
ever go above 1.
You can't believe
your most recent data
point more than 100%.
It's a ratio, or
fraction of the percent.
You can see that,
as r gets larger,
this multiplier starts
to approach some limit.
And finally, when r is equal to
1, this multiplier is simply 1.
In the limit, when r is equal
to 1, what are we doing?
We're doing 100% update based
on my most recent data point.
In other words, I'm only looking
at my most recent data point.
My variance is simply
the process variance
coming from sampling.
This all reduces to
[? simply ?] sigma
a being by sampling
variance, whatever
size sample I was doing
within each formulation.
So in that case, I have
no factor or no multiplier
on that sigma A. But for other
values of r, what's happening?
For smaller values
of r, what do we see?
The sigma A is smaller than
the sigma x over root n.
We're getting reduction in the
variance because of filtering,
the variance of our estimate.
So that was the whole idea
is I can tighten my control
limits, essentially by
the filtering action.
So as I get smaller
and smaller r's, I
do more and more
aggressive filtering
with lots of past data.
I get tighter and
tighter limits,
but of course, I'm also
suppressing recent data
little bit more heavily,
so there is this trade-off.
Let's look at some examples.
Oh, well, I guess I made
these points already here.
Again, the variance of this
estimate for the mean--
your best guess of the mean--
is smaller than you would
have had with an x bar chart,
because the x bar chart,
remember, for a sample
size of n, is simply that.
So we do get this suppression.
And it is very nice that
it also, in the limit,
works out for both the
sample size of 1 case--
these formulas still hold--
and also the full
update case, or the r
equals 1, where we have
completely unfiltered data.
You just plot in your pure
run data on your chart.
So what happens if I use
much smaller r's, like 0.1?
I got much tighter
control limits,
but I've got long delays
potentially then in detecting--
I've got a lot of
noise suppression,
but again, I get
back to long delays
in detecting or responding
to a true shift in the mean.
So I want to look at
a few examples here
to give you a feel of the
trade-off between different r's
for some data, and compare it as
well to a typical x bar chart.
OK, so here's a set of data, and
we're seeing a comparison here
between the x bar chart--
so you can see here are the
x bar upper and lower control
limits.
And sure enough, after
150 runs, where at--
I don't know-- about run
90, we make this shift
in the process--
so we shift the whole
process by a half
a standard deviation of
the underlying process.
And sure enough, by about--
I don't know-- run 140, we
finally got a data point
in the tail of the
mean distribution--
the regular x bar--
that fell out.
And we could actually calculate
the average run length
to detect a mean shift of 0.5
using some of the techniques we
talked about last time.
And we might not be happy
with that very long ARL,
and the question is, would an
EWMA chart help us with this?
And this is an
example where we're
using about a 30% update
based on each new data point,
and plotted in
purple with the blue
and the yellow are the
upper and lower control
limits for the EWMA.
And what you see is the
effect of averaging.
Now, I always find it's
easiest for me to conceptualize
the action of the EWMA chart
is just kind of like a moving
average-- the equally weighted
moving average, but weighted
a little bit more
towards recent history.
But the whole idea is
I get that aggregation
from any kind of a
moving average so that,
right after this
shift right here,
now, when I take into account--
with an r of 0.3, I'm taking
into account three, four, five
data points--
I've got kind of an
effective window weighted
about 30% towards my most
recent, but including
some past history--
that all of the
plus delta nu data
points all average, and then
my normal process variation
just cancels out each other.
And so it's very
intuitive, I think,
that this EWMA is going
to aggregate or respond
to or sense the delta
shift in the mean more
than an individual x bar
chart would have been doing--
so that it responds
in this case,
I don't know, after about
15 or 20 data points.
You can start to see excursions
beyond the control limit.
Question--
AUDIENCE: At the
beginning of the chart,
why are the control
limits [INAUDIBLE]
spreading [INAUDIBLE]?
The last time, they
were [INAUDIBLE]
DUANE BONING: Yes,
yes-- good point.
I think you can go back to this
formula and see if that works.
I bet, if you look at
the effective the t
action, formulaically
or analytically,
I think that, as t starts
out being very small--
so if t is 0, this
is essentially 1.
Well, let's say t was 1 and
r was 0.3, I've got 0.7.
I've got a reduction.
So I think, for
small t, I've only
got a limited amount of
data, and so I'm not--
I don't have the long
tail in the EWMA.
So I think I've only got
a small amount of data
with a larger weight
in my control limits
I think are smaller.
But then, as t gets larger,
I've got a little bit more
and more data until t--
so I think if I were
to plot this 1 minus 1
minus r to the 2t--
kind of has a funky
shape that dies out.
But I wouldn't worry too
much about the startup times.
There are artifacts when you
start up a control chart,
but once you just start
a control chart anyway,
you're still feeling
out the process,
so I wouldn't worry too
much about the startup
times on these.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] How do
you get this side [INAUDIBLE]
DUANE BONING: Yeah.
So the question is-- if you
didn't hear that in Singapore--
was, when would you
use an EWMA or what
are the factors in using an
EWMA from an x bar chart?
And I think, if you've
got a lot of noise
and you're really worried
about detecting rapidly a shift
in the process, an EWMA--
and we'll see the
CUSUM in a minute--
has improved sensitivity to
rapid detection of the shift.
But it comes at one
really important cost,
which is a loss in transparency
in what's going on.
The x bar, I think,
conceptually,
is a lot easier to
understand, have
everybody on the line
understand what it is.
The data, if you also explode
out and show the full data--
the x bar and the s--
gives you a good feel
directly to the statistics
of the process.
Here you look at this
and you lose touch,
I think, a little bit
with the statistics of--
and the relationship
to your raw data.
It's a little harder to
get your mind around.
I don't know-- 10, 15 years ago,
I fell in love with the EWMA
chart and approach--
not only for charting,
but also for doing
simple run-by-run control.
And so I kind of
like it, but I can
empathize with it being a
little bit harder to explain
and maintain on the line.
It's also got a little bit
more calculation, so back
in the days of--
and it's still true in some
of the manufacturing lines.
I know, when we went on the
tour and some of the plants--
very, very up-to-date
plants in Singapore
and other places around
the world, people
are still often taking
measurements by hand,
and doing the hand calculation,
and writing it on a chart.
This has an extra step.
You've got to do
an extra average.
So in modern day, when
almost all the calculations
are automated.
And the data collection
is automated.
I think there's even more
reason to go with an EWMA.
So the thing I like about
the best about the EWMA is I
think of it as giving me my
best current estimate based
not only on just my last
data point, but a little bit
of filtering,
including past history.
It's giving my best educated
state of the current process.
And why I like that for
then run-by-run control is,
based on my current
model, my updated--
on a recursive
basis, updated model
of the current state of the
process I can make a decision.
So here the decision in SPC is
the process in control or not
'But if you think of this
being not just the EWMA not--
giving you more information.
It's not just giving you,
am I in control or not,
given the random spread?
But if you interpret
this little purple data
point here as my best
estimate of where
the mean in the
recent past has been,
if there is a little bit
of drift or movement maybe.
I do active control and
not pure SPC control.
I'm not making any
longer just the decision.
Nothing has changed.
I'm saying there
are small changes,
and maybe I want to go and
make a small modification
or an adjustment
on the equipment.
Now.
If, you are in true
statistical process control,
that would be the
wrong thing to do.
You'd be over-adjusting, and
we'll talk about that later.
But that's another thing I like
about the EWMA is very often,
there is a little bit of time
correlation in the process.
And the EWMA is tracking
those small changes
and filtering out
some of the noise.
It's a good question.
I'll take a question.
There was somebody had
a question in Singapore.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
So under smaller r will lead
to the narrow control limit,
right?
DUANE BONING: That's right.
AUDIENCE: That's so the
narrow control limit--
you will have a smaller beta?
DUANE BONING: So a smaller
beta would be less chance--
AUDIENCE: Smaller beta?
DUANE BONING: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
[INAUDIBLE] type II error.
DUANE BONING: Right-- but
its power is then larger,
so the chance of detecting
a true out of control point
increases.
But there's a very important
additional factor, which
is there's additional time lag.
So I'm going to show
a couple of examples,
because you can see
in other examples
the effective the filtering and
the time response that it takes
to detect can go up.
AUDIENCE: OK.
DUANE BONING: So
another question here--
AUDIENCE: I'm was just curious.
What sample size were you
using for the x bar chart?
DUANE BONING: I don't know.
I'm not sure what
was used in the--
as a sample size.
I think you're just seeing
the plot of the sample,
so the sample size is actually
the same in both cases.
But I don't what was being used.
In some sense, it doesn't
actually matter too much.
The EWMA is looking--
is an EWMA over sample.
I might have 1,000
parts an hour,
and every 15 minutes, I
might do a sample size of 10.
So I'm only getting
sample size 10, lots more.
And what's being plotted here,
in some sense, is the sample.
So I have an x bar where I
might plot those samples.
Here what I'm doing--
the EWMA has enough-- it has
the flexibility to extend to n
equals 1 sampling, if
that's what I'm doing.
But in some sense,
it could also be
used where, instead of each of
those n equals 10 samples was
the only data I looked at.
Each one of those is my t--
point in t, and my previous
sample of size 10 is t minus 1.
So in some sense, it's doing
the whole sample-by-sample
comparison.
So my point here
was both the EWMA
and the x bar are using, in
this derivation, the same sample
size.
I'm not differentiating in that.
All I'm doing in this
case really, with the EWMA
is using multiple
samples back in time,
and the x bar only uses one.
So in fact, if I go to r
equals 1, the two converge.
They are the same.
The r equals EWMA is exactly
the same as the x bar.
AUDIENCE: But the
larger my sample size
is the less of a spread
I get between my two--
[INAUDIBLE]
DUANE BONING: They would
both go together, though,
because I had to
have the factor.
So back here on slide 12,
if I change my sample size,
both sigma A and my
upper control limits
and lower federal limits for the
x bar shrink exactly the same.
So I would scale both
of them, if I increase.
So what I was talking about here
is with different values of r.
So this was an r equals 0.3.
Here's a smaller
r, r equals 0.1.
So what's happening here?
I'm only accepting my most
recent data point 10%,
and mixing past history and 90%.
That's more averaging
of the past.
I'm using more past
history, and so
in this case, what you see is
kind of a more slowly drifting,
more heavily--
excuse me-- more heavily
filtered version.
And here, with the mean
shift occurring about here,
you can start to
see in this case
a big mean shift at 0.5 with,
I guess, a sample size of 5.
You do need to know the
sample size in order
to know the effect of the
mean shift and ability
to detect with either chart.
So somewhere in here--
I guess around there--
I got I got lucky, and
I'm starting to sample now
with the x bar picking
up that detection.
But with the EWMA, in some
sense, I've still got 90%.
It takes 9 or 10 data points
for the more recent data
to outweigh the past
data, and so I've actually
got, in this case, a
time lag in detecting
the mean shift with the
EWMA compared to the x bar.
So a question here first--
AUDIENCE: I don't see
how we can compare them
because they actually are
different time scales.
All the x bar will
effectively-- let
us say the sample
size is [INAUDIBLE]
DUANE BONING: So the question
was, how do you compare
the time scales on these?
So here's what I
think is going on.
And this is sort of what I
was talking about a second m
but it's probably still
a little confusing.
I believe that this n
equals 5 sample size means
that, inside of this data point,
if I were to explode that,
it actually has five
data points inside of it.
And I'm only plotting the
average of those five on here.
This data point also has
those same five data points,
but then it also
grabbed the data
that was lurking in
the previous one.
And it has its five data
points and its five--
whoops.
Yah!
Don't want to--
I think it was trying
to exit me out here.
So while it's doing
that, the point
here was that the n equals
5 is not looking back
five data points in the x bar.
It's buried in each of
the individual points--
so that both EWMA
and x bar are not
affected by this n equals
5 sampling differently.
But then the time scale
is correct in terms of--
x bar only looks at
my most recent sample.
The EWMA does look
back in history,
and that's why you've got
this additional time lag.
Was that getting at your
question or your observation,
or is your question
a little different?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DUANE BONING: OK.
OK.
And there was a
question in Singapore.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
So my question is
sort of built on what
[? Stephen ?] was asking.
So for a smaller r, you
have a higher probability
of detecting a mean shift.
But at same time,
for a smaller r,
the time it takes for you
to detect the mean shift
is longer.
How does these two coexist?
Well, you have a higher
chance of detecting it,
but it takes longer as well.
DUANE BONING: Yes.
They're a trade-off.
And so what you are basically
given is a degree of freedom
that you get to play
with, or experiment with,
or adapt to your process.
So what are the factors in
adapting to your process?
If your process is
really noisy and you
think it's going to
be hard to detect
a mean shift in the
phase of that noise,
then you do more averaging.
You'd have a smaller r.
If you're trying to detect--
maybe with a higher
risk of a false alarm,
but you're trying to
detect more quickly,
then I'd have a larger
r, so it responds faster,
but doesn't filter as much.
So you can see here, with
the r equals 0.1 versus the r
equals 0.3--
this is the same
data, I believe.
Is this the same data?
I guess not-- it's
just another example.
Here's an r equals 0.3 kind
of case, where, for this data,
this looks like about
the right trade-off.
I'm getting
reasonable filtering.
The black dots are my EWMA.
And for a mean shift here,
I've got very rapid--
I've got rapid detection,
much more rapid than,
in fact, the x bar,
which doesn't really
trigger finally until way--
another 20, 25 runs later.
So I think what you'd have to
do is, again make the trade-offs
between responsivity,
the size of the shift
that you're trying
to detect, and how
much cost you to have different
delays in detecting the shift.
So we've got two questions
here-- one here first.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
It's almost
like you are taking
a larger sample size.
[INAUDIBLE] You're taking
the 5 samples for--
5 measurements per sample, plus
5 previously or slightly lower
[INAUDIBLE] plus 5 [INAUDIBLE]
plus 5 [INAUDIBLE] So
you're just taking
more samples per--
more measurements per
data point, right?
DUANE BONING: Yes.
So that's a fair way
of looking at it.
That's a good way
So just so everybody could
hear, with the x bar,
I take my n equals whatever
sample, but with the EWMA,
I still got that from
my most recent update,
but I'm doing
additional filtering
or averaging of past history in.
And the net effective that
is I've got a net aggregate--
more number of
samples, if you will--
unequally weighted, but a more--
and therefore, that
makes perfect sense
that your control
limits come down.
That's a very good
way of looking at it.
AUDIENCE: So in the
previous example,
does EWMA also
trigger before x bar?
Because x bar [INAUDIBLE]
DUANE BONING: Oh, yes-- good
point, good point-- yes.
AUDIENCE: Is there ever a
case when x bar will trigger
[INAUDIBLE]
DUANE BONING: Good
question-- are there ever
situations where x bar
might trigger still
before an EWMA for
an x bar chart?
I don't quite know
the trade-offs
and where you get in the
limits of the trade-off.
You've always got
chance at work,
and I suspect that,
with a large enough--
so the following scenario
probably comes closest.
Let's say you had a very large
mean shift, but a very small r.
With an x bar, I react
entirely to a sample drawn
from the very large mean shift.
Let's say it was a 2 sigma
or a 3 sigma means shift.
But I have a very small r.
Maybe I'm only
calling that 0.05.
That 5% mix in of that
most recent data point
is probably swamped out
by my past data still,
and so in that case, I think
my EWMA would likely not
detect the mean shift.
So I think of the EWMA
as especially good
for improving
responsivity and detection
ability for small effects,
because it's aggregating,
just like the CUSUM that
we'll see in a second.
But I think, if there are
really big-- bigger effects,
you lose by the filtering
in the time response.
Was that an example
you're going to suggest?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DUANE BONING: Oh, good point--
DUANE BONING: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
Yeah.
So other rules here would
help-- yeah, absolutely.
OK, so I guess this is
sort of saying a little bit
the same thing.
This, I think, is really
good for small mean shifts--
that are persistent.
It's not a one-time shot, that
I've got a delta mu mean shift,
and this allows us to aggregate.
There are additional
ideas we can use.
Yeah-- question [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DUANE BONING: No, you
would not want to--
so I think Hayden's
point here was
on the purple beta
points you might apply,
which was just an x bar.
You might apply the WECO
but you should not--
there might be variants
you could derive
some of the other WECO
rules, but I don't
know how you would do that.
It's not intuitive.
I think, for the
EWMA, you pretty much
are just trying
to track the mean,
and not additional trends or--
I would not use any of
the additional WECO rules
with an EWMA chart.
So there's another chart
that is very often used.
It's called a CUSUM I
just want to give you
a quick feel for
that, and then move
to some multivariate issues,
which is also targeted
at this idea that, when
I have a small mean,
shift what I'd like to do
is use the fact that it is
a persistent mean shift that
I'm then sampling around
within the process noise.
And if there were a
simple way to aggregate
the mean shift algorithm
many data points in the past,
I'd build up a signal that's
larger and might improve
my ability to detect that effect
and reduce the average run
length for detecting
that effect.
And this CUSUM,
or cumulative sum,
is another way of thinking
of it as a filter--
and in this case,
just a discrete time
integrator-- which is looking
at the sum of deviations
of each of my sample point
from the assumed grand mean.
So I'm not just filtering
and plotting the average,
but I'm saying--
asking the question, am I still
in control at my assumed x bar
bar, my mu 0?
And if I'm not,
then this statistic,
this sum of being to one
side of it, the c sub j
here will grow if I've
got a plus mean shift,
or become more and more
negative and grow if I've
got a negative mean shift--
so that I'll convert a mean
shift to an integration
of a mean shift.
The mean shift is a step.
The integration of a
step response is a ramp.
So what we would hope
to do with a CUSUM chart
is improve our mean
shift sensitivity,
and basically have charts
that look like this.
When I'm in control, I might
wander around the mean.
Sometimes I'll be
above, sometimes below,
so this c sub j, this
cumulative statistic,
does wander around a bit.
But if I do have a
mean shift, on average,
I keep adding to that C sub J.
Sometimes I might go
down a little bit,
because I still have something
a little bit below the mean.
And so what you
create is this ramp.
You create a slope caused
by that mean shift.
Now, one can also now
apply some statistics
and design, control limits
for that C sub J statistic,
or use a couple of
other approaches.
And one approach is this
so-called V-Mask that says it--
what I would like to do is, if,
in fact, I've got a mean shift,
this slope--
let me erase a little bit here--
whoops-- so there are two
different approaches--
and I just want
to briefly mention
both of those-- for detecting
things on these charts.
One is draw a control limit
for the aggregate of the C sub
J. The other is to look and say,
once I've got a mean shift, I
start building data points with,
on average, some slope that
is different than a slope that
I would expect by random chance
alone, just forming the sum
statistic from a normally
sampled process.
The tabular CUSUM-- this
idea of actually looking
at the statistics of--
let me skip this for a second--
this normalized
statistic z and s,
and looking and deciding on what
control limits are, and so on--
I'm actually going to skip that.
There's about five
slides in here,
but it's described very nicely
in, I think, chapter 8.1
in Montgomery.
And I think that's
pretty natural.
It's just sort of a statistic--
a little bit confusing
derivation of the
statistics that--
I just trust the statisticians
who have done right.
But there's also
another picture here,
which is based on
the slope idea.
And you can similarly
derive some formulas
based on alpha and beta
risks, what size of a delta
shift in the mean you
would hope to detect,
and what kind of a slope
you would expect to see,
in those cases.
And so you've got these
two parameters that
go towards the
formulation of this V-Mask
that you overlay
on your data points
based on an expected slope,
and you need a certain number
of data points in order
to be able to build up
your estimate of the slope.
That's the dead zone.
And what you do for each
data point here is overlay
the V-Mask and say, look
back in time and see,
did any of these points
intersect with the mask--
have a higher slope than
you would have expected?
And then you update
that on a running basis.
So in this case,
here at time point
18 or 19-- whatever that
is-- everything looks fine.
I go up.
Everything is
still looking fine.
Still here, I'm starting
to get some evidence maybe
that things have changed,
but statistically speaking,
that's still within
the range that I would
expect with some alpha error.
But then finally, I get to a
new data point here at time 23,
where, in aggregate,
I've got some indication
that the slope is too large.
So this is kind of a intuitive
graphical approach that's
talking about the
slope associated
with a mean shift in
the CUSUM statistic.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Would you also
perform a linear regression
for the last three or four
parts and check the [INAUDIBLE]??
DUANE BONING: So the
question is, can you
perform a linear regression and
calculate the slope of that?
And I think that's identical to
what this is doing graphically.
So in fact, if you
were numerically--
or implementing an
automatic version of this,
that would probably be how
you would implement it.
That might even give you
some more flexibility
in terms of looking at
the goodness of that fit,
but I think it's essentially
identical to this.
OK.
So just to summarize
these alternative charts,
there's a few simple messages.
Noisy data-- if you're
trying to detect
a mean in the noisy
data, you might
want to use some filtering.
We have the sample size
that does some filtering,
but I might want
to use more data
in the past and this
linear discrete filtering,
either with the CUSUM as a
running integrator or an EWMA--
which is an iterative
discrete filter--
can be applied.
And I think,
conceptually, they're
fairly nice in terms of
that noise suppression
for detecting of the mean--
got to remember that
your choice of factors,
like r and the EWMA, depends
on your process, and the mix
of noise, and how fast
you want to respond to be
able to detect a mean shift.
And then, going back to what we
started with our little example
at the very beginning.
Noisy data need some filtering.
We've talked about it
with respect to the mean--
that, if I'm
filtering that data,
you also still want to look
back and monitor the variance
as well.
So you can apply these charts
also to moving, S bar charts,
and so on.
So what I want to
do next is move
a little bit to multivariate
process control,
control charting when I've got
more than one parameter that I
may be monitoring on the unit
process or on the product.
And what's really
interesting here
is there are essentially
two classic mistakes that
are made again and again.
And I want to give you a
feel for those two mistakes,
and strategies
for avoiding them.
OK?
One classic problem is you've
got more than one parameter
you're monitoring-- you
implement more than one control
chart--
seems natural.
But the problem is you can get
many, many, many more false
alarms than you might
have expected, or believed
you are going to get,
because you're just
monitoring more parameters.
And so I want to talk a
little bit about that.
That's even if
there's no correlation
between your parameters--
or especially if
there's no correlation
between your parameters,
you can get--
just by the fact that you're
monitoring more than one thing,
you've got to think about
false alarm rate a little bit
differently.
And then the second
classic problem
is, well, there is correlation
among the parameters--
the multiple parameters.
How do you deal with that?
And in fact, in
this case, you often
run into the opposite risk.
Instead of too
many false alarms,
you may have points
of data or product
that is truly out
of normal operation
that you may not detect.
It's a highly unusual
point that may in
indicate something has
changed in your process,
but if you're just monitoring
with univariate control charts,
you'll never see it.
That is a common
mistake number two.
Multiple charts is common
mistake number one first.
If I truly have independent
parameters being modeled--
monitored at my process step,
and I set each one of them
up to have some
acceptable alpha rate--
false alarm rate--
1 out of every 370 process
steps going with a plus/minus
three-sigma--
three-sigma control limits,
alpha's about 0.0027--
sometimes talked about
0.003 as an approximation.
But now I've got p of
those separate charts.
What is the aggregate
false alarm probability?
Well to be careful about
it, if they are, in fact,
independent, that alpha prime,
might aggregate false alarm,
is, 1 minus 1 minus
alpha to the p.
This is the probability
that I don't
get a false alarm for each of--
for all of the other p control
charts all at the same time.
And then 1 minus
that is the chance
that I did get one of them.
Now for very small alpha, you
do that expansion, the 1 minus x
for small x to the p is simply
1 minus x So you do that
and you get sort of the
nice intuitive result
that if I've got 10
independent control charts,
I've got about 10 times
the rate of false alarm
that I would have from one.
So what do you do?
What would you do?
Let me say it this way.
You've decided, based on your
cost analysis or whatever,
that you're willing
about once every 370 runs
to have a false alarm
somewhere on this process,
that you want to at
least-- look at maybe
you look at it real quickly.
It doesn't take a long time.
But that's about how often
you want the operator to stop
and take a look, on average,
even when the process is
in control.
So that's your false alarm rate
that you're willing to accept,
but you're monitoring
10 parameters.
[INAUDIBLE] some
approaches you would use?
AUDIENCE: You have to
increase your control limits.
DUANE BONING: Right, perfect--
you would increase
your control limits.
If I expand my control
limits out a little bit,
I have smaller false
alarm rate on each chart.
Well, I can basically decide
what my aggregate false alarm
rate would be--
1 out of 370.
And to set my false alarm
rate on each individual chart,
just divide by how
many charts I have.
Now, I might have a 1 in 3,700
false alarm rate on each chart,
and I use that new alpha
to set my control limit.
They might end up being, in
that case, plus minus 3.4
sigma control limits.
So the individual false alarm
rate is lower on each one,
because really, the
question you are asking--
the key question was not
that individual parameter,
but rather, the question,
is my process in control?
In aggregate, do I have an
event that looks unlikely--
so unlikely that I have 1
minus alpha confidence, 1 minus
alpha prime confidence, that,
in fact, something unusual
is going on in the process?
So that's a strategy.
I want to also point out-- and
this is kind of a neat little
article that I found last year--
that this is a more
generic problem,
a more generic common mistake
than just control charting.
It applies all the time, when
people are doing significance
tests or hypothesis tests, but
doing more than one of them
at a time.
Control charge is just a
running hypothesis test.
Now, if I'm checking
10 hypotheses,
10 control charts,
and 10 parameters.
My aggregate false
alarm rate is higher.
And there's this
neat little article
pulled from-- that I found in
The Economist last February
that's called "Medical
Statistics Signs of the Times."
The subtitle here--
you may not be
able to read it-- is, "Why So
Much Medical Research is Rot."
I'll read you the first
couple of sentences here.
People born under the
astrological sign of Leo
are 15% more likely
to be admitted
to hospital with
gastric bleeding
than those born with
the other 11 signs.
Sagittarians are 38% more
likely than others to land up
there because of a broken arm.
Those are the conclusions
that many medical researchers
would be forced to make
from a set of data presented
to the American Association
for the Advancement of Science.
At least they would be
forced to draw them,
if they applied the
lax statistical methods
of their own work to the
records of hospital admissions
in Ontario, Canada.
And the basic confusion
drawn here in the red
arises because each result
is tested separately
to see how likely
in statistical terms
it was to have happen by chance.
If the likelihood is below
a certain threshold--
typically 95%--
so we've got a 95% confidence,
which says, 1 in 20 times,
by chance alone, I might
see a signal that big--
by chance alone.
And now I check 12--
maybe astrological
sign is your 12 things
I'm checking for as factors--
and I've got a 1 in 20 chance,
and I check 12 of them--
probably I'm going to
pop up and say, oh,
that one's significant.
And so that's exactly
the same common mistake
that you can see with
multiple control charts.
And so the point here would
simply be you should--
if you're checking
multiple factors,
you got to have a stronger
indication at any one factor--
otherwise, you're just fishing,
and by chance alone, you're
going to find stuff.
So that's kind of
a neat example.
And so here was the point I
made about how you fix it.
You just fix your
aggregate alpha prime,
you have your individual
alpha, and then
you pick your upper and
lower control limits
based on that alpha.
There's a second common
problem, and as I said,
it's the obverse of this,
which is you very often assume
that, if I'm monitoring 10
process control parameters,
I assume they're
all independent.
But very often, they are not.
There is correlation
among those parameters,
and I want to give you a little
bit of a feel for what that
looks like, and
what the risk is,
and what approaches are for
control charting and particular
of this.
So here's an example
drawn from some data that
came from an LFM
thesis a few years ago,
a body and white assembly.
So body and white-- this is
when they are basically putting
together all of the different
panels on the car and measuring
many, many points with
all kinds of laser,
automated apparatus to be able
to look at dimensional control
of these panels
in the assembly--
of some of these panels.
Other correlated data comes
up all over the place--
injection molding-- I
think we're missing--
I can't remember his name.
He asked a question last time
about critical dimensions
on a semiconductor wafer.
Yes, they are often correlated.
But here's the body
and white example,
and what I'm sort of showing
are these little coordinate
measuring machine, CMM
kinds of measurements.
I have a few of these
different data points.
And the point is, if I
think of this as a metal
panel in some way, and I'm
measuring the position, say,
of these four corner points,
you would expect there
to be correlation among them.
And certain kinds of
distortion might change
relationships between them.
And in fact, you might even
come up with other statistics,
like a y1, and a
y3, and a y4, that
try to detect or
look at tracking
of a couple of these
parameters and deviations.
But the point is I
wouldn't necessarily
want to monitor those
four corner locations
as independent parameters.
Here's another example.
This comes from an ultrasonic
welding set of data.
And you may not be
able to see this.
This is a wonderful correlation
plot of three, four, five, six,
seven, eight, 10 different
parameters against each other.
There are different things, like
P2 weld energy, P2 peak power.
These are simply
scatter plots of data
drawn from that process.
You can see some of these
parameters that track down--
that's total weld energy
versus P2 weld energy.
I don't even know what
those things mean,
but they sure sound like
they're going to be correlated,
don't they?
And sure enough, there's
extremely strong correlation
in that data.
There's other cases
where there's also
fairly strong correlation.
So again, these kinds
of correlated data,
where knowing something
about one of the measurements
tells you about the likelihood
of the other measurement,
occur all the time.
So what if you have truly
random independent variables?
What would a scatter
plot look like,
and how do we go about
setting the control limits?
That's pretty natural, right?
So here's an example
where we had x1 and x2.
The scatterplot basically
looks like a cloud of data--
and if I added more
data, you start to--
depending on the
scaling, if I were simply
to draw, say, a joint
95% confidence integral,
it's just kind of
a cloud of data,
but there's no cross
information between x1 and x2.
In other words, if I told
you that x1 was right here--
the value of x1 was this value--
that really doesn't tell me
very much about what value of x2
could be.
It still falls anywhere
within its distribution.
These are two independent
random variables.
And you can decide what
the proper limits are.
Now you know enough
about picking x1 and x2,
and I would do the
alpha prime idea
to pick independent
limits on those two cases.
This is an example
scatterplot for
correlated random variables.
And in this case, it starts to
look like an oval or a football
kind of shape, where there
is statistical correlation
between these two parameters--
by which I mean, if I tell
you that x1 is in this range,
that tells you something
about where the value of x2
is likely to fall.
It might not fall within
its full natural range.
There is cross information
or cross-correlation
between the two.
Now, if I were to plot
x1 and x2 separately,
it looks an awful lot like
the uncorrelated case.
So if I had independent control
charts for the two variables,
essentially what
I'm doing is just
projecting all of
these data points.
I project all of these data
points to get my range for x2,
and I project all of
these data points.
And in fact, if I plot
both of those, x1 and x2,
I would likely get--
yikes-- don't want to do that--
I would likely get two separate,
normally distributed variables,
and I might be inclined
to simply plot them
both as x bar and S
kinds of control charts.
The risk here,
though, when you do
that is you might
miss outliers, data
points that do not fall in the
normal or the natural variation
of the process--
this being the natural
variation of the process
that I will not detect.
This data point still looks like
it's within that distribution.
In, fact, it's very
close to the mean of x2.
And it's still within
this distribution.
But within the natural
variation of the process,
within that oval, its
distance, in some sense,
from the central moments
of that distribution--
it's pretty distant.
It's not indicative of
the normal operation.
It's a highly unlikely,
by chance alone, data
point, and I would never
see it on the control chart.
So there are
multivariate charts that
let us get at and chart
on a single chart--
multiple factors that
are correlated together--
and detect those
kinds of problems.
What I want to give
you is a notion first
of a statistic that
aggregates, in some sense--
numerically aggregates
exactly what
I was talking about
qualitatively here,
that tells you this
notion of, what
is the distance from
the correlated variation
cloud of each of my
measurement points?
And if I have a statistic
and I know it's PDF,
then I can set control
limits on that statistic.
And that statistic is
the Hotelling T squared,
is one very important one.
We can also monitor--
have EWMA and CUSUM
extensions of these.
Which I'm not really
going to talk much about.
So what we have to do here
is have a slight extension
to our notion of a
probability density function
to have joint probability
density functions that tell me
if I've got, say, two
variables-- or three, or four,
whatever-- what is the
probability density associated
with those?
And what we want is a
single scale control
chart that aggregates these.
Now, I've got a little bit
of mathematical notation
in here that I'm not going to
go through the careful full
explanation or derivation of.
What I want to
simply show you is
how a multivariate expression
of the same variables we've
been using all along gives you
a nice qualitative feel for what
this statistic looks like.
So if we have a vector
of measurements--
let's have p parameters--
I'm measuring 10
different parameters--
body in white or whatever it is
for that particular process--
and put those in an x--
underscore, an x vector.
And then I can define
a vector of means.
So I have a set of means
for all 10 parameters.
And I can also calculate,
if I have lots and lots
of historical data.
There isn't a true
underlying covariance matrix
that talks about or
characterizes how these data go
together with each other.
Now, I can estimate
that covariance matrix
based on sample
data, so I similarly
have a true mean and
a true covariance.
Then I might estimate
with an x bar and an S--
here I'm using a capital S--
to be a sample
covariance matrix.
And there are formulas
in the book using
a very simple linear, matrix--
linear algebra for
how you would do that,
given a particular set of data.
And they look a lot like
the univariate example.
But I did want to
point out that there's
both embedded in this
the notion of variance--
how variable 2 varies
together with variable 2--
that's just our normal
notion of variance.
And there's also covariance--
that is, a measure of how these
two variables move together.
We can actually write out what
the PDFs probability density
functions-- are in
these joint cases.
And if you write it
in matrix form using
this covariance matrix
and the mu vector,
it looks almost exactly the
same as the univariate case.
Notice that, instead of
variance in the univariate case,
now we have the
covariance matrix.
And similarly, instead of just
x and u being univariate values,
I've got those as vectors.
But the PDF looks
almost exactly the same.
And qualitatively, you're
getting an exponential
drop-off, this e drop-off with
the square of the distance
of a point from the mean--
the normalized distance
from the point.
So if we look back
at the univariate,
the whole idea is I subtract
off the mean when I standardize,
divide by the natural
variation, and that tells me
the shape of the bell curve--
shape of the normal curve,
how fast things drop off.
And I can also, for any
particular multivariate u--
multivariate data point x that
has its 10 parameters in it--
what's really cool is
this formulation here
of the distance of that x
vector from the mean point--
the main vector squared--
that squared distance, but
weighted then or normalized
to the natural spread--
that natural spread or
width of that cloud--
is just a distance measure--
squared distance
measure of each data
point from the central
moment of the central point
of the distribution, scaled
to how much natural spread
or scatter there is in the data.
OK, so that's the PDF.
Those are just the formulas
for the sample use cases.
What I can now go in and
do is ask the question,
what is the distribution
associated with that distance
metric?
And that distance
metric is essentially--
if I expand out that
distance formula,
it is a sum of squared distances
normalized to the correlation,
which starts to sound like
sum of squared unit normal
variables, which was our
chi-squared distribution--
sum of squared normal--
so what's cool here is that the
chi-squared distribution with p
parameters--
p degrees of freedom--
is the right statistic for
measuring how likely it
is to see those
distance-- the T squared,
those distance metrics.
So one can actually
have the PDF.
One can have the
distribution for that PDF,
and based on that, you
can formulate or form a--
that statistic based
on my actual data x.
and then I can have
an alpha squared
that I can pick my cutoff
points from appropriately.
Oops-- I thought I had
a PDF in here somewhere.
So when I'm making
a control chart,
I use the same ideas
that we saw before.
I have a false alarm rate.
In this case, I'm going
to aggregate all my data
onto a single control
chart so I can just
use my aggregate alpha.
And I pick the tail points on
the chi-squared distribution.
Remember, a chi-squared
might have looked something
like this, and I might pick a
way out here as my chi-squared
so that I've got my alpha
out there in the tail.
That picks my cutoff point
for my upper control limit.
Generally, you can also do
that for a lower control limit.
Very often, if you do some--
apply some of these formulas,
the lower control
limit is negative.
And you can't have
negative square,
so you pick 0 as your
lower control limit.
And you're really only
monitoring four data points
that are larger than--
I've got more variation in
my system than I expected.
So just to close up on this
univariate versus chi-squared
chart, here's an example--
comparing the univariate case
up here to the multivariate case
down here.
And what I'm plotting here is,
again, the scatter of data.
You might see there's a
slight shaded oval case.
And all the blue
data points are what
I would do if I just projected
those down to an x1 and x2,
and did univariate
control charting.
If I then had this little
red dot that fell outside
of the joint
confidence interval--
on my individual charts,
notice where it falls--
perfectly within
the control limits--
nothing that tells me that
that point is unusual.
But if I then plot
that data point--
that red data point there and
on the chi-squared chart--
I calculated the chi statistic,
that distance statistic--
that would trigger, because
its distance from the mean
is unusual.
Now, if I actually didn't know
my true covariance matrix,
but I had to estimate it, I have
to estimate sigma with an s.
I'm right back to
this whole difference
between a t and a unit normal.
So just to close
this out we often
talk about these as t-squared,
Hotelling t-squared statistics,
but it's exactly the same idea.
And it's got its
own cut-off points.
OK, so with that, I think we've
pulled to a close on control
charting for the--
at least for the time being.
Next time, we'll start
diving in on yield modeling
and different uses
of some statistics,
but I think what
you've got now is
some exposure to EWMA, CUSUM.
You'll play around with those
with the three or four problems
on this week's problem set.
And start looking
at the quizzes.
We'll have the first
quiz a week from today--
in class.
AUDIENCE: Professor,
I have a question.
DUANE BONING: Yeah.
Go ahead and break.
I'll take your question
while people are dispersing.
AUDIENCE: So for the
[INAUDIBLE] you taught us today,
are they going to be
included in the quiz?
DUANE BONING: It's possible
you'll see an EWMA or a CUSUM,
but they would only be fairly
simple questions for those.
It's not likely you'll see
a multivariate problem.
AUDIENCE: OK, thank you.